you mentioned that passivism and the
idea that the kingdom of God is breaking
in or the world is being remade and you
know about our link could you mention
just more about that right how we doing
put some okay right right well this is a
side theme but it's one that's been a
center to my concerns because once a
phantom fundamentals background
introduces you to the the new test makes
the new testament you or your guide you
have to face the fact that it is the
part of the repertoire sent to the
repertoire is the prohibit prohibition
of violence and so the question then
becomes how is it that a religion that
was that was so strong and on the issue
of non-violence only one is considerably
stronger than that's Buddhism how does
that religion becomes part of the power
system and that that's that is pretty
well the most fundamental question you
can ask about how is it that a
repertoire which is so anti violence
come can actually become part of the
political system that is inherently
based on force and which can even
justify the idea of the crusade now how
does that happen I believe is the whole
of the sociology of religion can be
understood if you simply work out how
that can occur the shift from a
voluntary group which is separated from
the structures of power and which
rejects violence and expects and expects
a transformation in human relations
where violence will not be an essential
part of it we're actually mutuality and
the and the relationships the mutual
relationships the new jerusalem the new
city will actually be be instantiated
how does that once it's incorporated in
the structures of
come to hold that the Roman Empire is a
kind of version of New Jerusalem so that
the the gates and the board of the New
Jerusalem needed to be offended against
the barbarians so that Rome Anytus and
Christianity become closely in turf used
how that these the structures of of
power on which any society rests now
this is a crucial bit any society rest
become built into the way in which the
religion understands itself and how it
then defends the borders of its
particular Imperium against other
alternative forms of world religion I'm
sort of sketching how this works and
very in a very rapid way originally when
I wanted to study pacifism because I I
was a pacifist and I undid myself in the
after ten years of study I i undid my
own belief Richard it is a hard thing to
happen but but I did conclude that all
societies are to some extent found it
founded on an element of force that
that's inherent but they're also that
the relationships between societies are
our our semi a Hobbesian flying put it
that way that international relations we
have international relations students
here are on a highly competitive
competitive interested basis the
expansion of power and at the expense of
other people and every head hegemon is
trying to defend its particular
hegemonic position against other
possible regimens so once you have that
system which and by the way it's not
simply it is not just religions that do
this there was a
form of political eschatology of
political hope or political utopia which
said exactly the same thing if only we
find that form if only we can eliminate
that element in human society that is
causing this eg religion then we can
have peace right so the actually
argument of religion was turned against
itself by political forms of utopia what
happened those political forms of utopia
proved to exhibit exactly the same
characteristics as have been exhibited
by established Christianity then the
question becomes what is it about the
constitution of society that means
whether you have a political expectation
or religious expectation there is a deep
built-in resistance and I'm not going to
develop that now but that is the
question that I think this seminar
pretty well has to investigate